this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by talkspace
more on that later let's get into the
dew the honeydew
with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here
doing it at studio night pants i'm ryan
sickler ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on
social media
uh make sure you are subscribed to the
youtube page
let's go and subscribe there watch video
there every tuesday
uh and if you or someone you know you
think
have a great story you'd like to hear or
be told or whatever
heard listened to please email me
at honeydewpodcast gmail.com and submit
for the honeydew with you all where i
highlight the low lights
with y'all social media all that stuff
you can find on the honeydewpodcast.com
i want to say thank you night pants
nation we are
strong and growing got a little shorter
with the night shorts
so hit up that merch store you got
coffee mugs there now look at these
coffee mugs
uh the charcoal hoodies in there all of
it it's all there go there
the honeydewpodcast.com also
santa monica music center offering
online classes from los angeles
musicians go to santa monicamusic.com
use code honeydew they'll waive the
registration fee
and give you a free first lesson uh when
you sign up for a package
now that that is all out of the way uh
as i always say we're over here
highlighting the low lights and these
are the stories behind the storytellers
and it's
wonderful to have this storyteller back
uh ladies and gentlemen please welcome
adam ray y'all welcome back to the do
adam right
bing that's your flattering sound effect
that's ours okay good okay okay good i
love it
good to see you yeah you impressive
upgrade thank you the studio the space
uh if you're fortunate enough to get to
tour the uh honeydew studios
i don't know if you're doing any sort of
those like giveaways you know like ben
and jerry's tour
yeah or after like the wheel fortune
they're like if you want a tour of the
fortune studios
or to see what pat sajak's jacket smells
like post show
you know uh p.o box so you at some point
i feel like you're building towards
you know the fans wanting to you know
win a trip or if they're out here or
i'm sure that happens anyway right where
they're like yo can i see where the
magic happens can i get a mug
i mean everyone knows where we are i
don't keep it
quiet because you know you wanna music
center
is you know it's pretty public yeah uh
but also after everything that happened
during the
the um uh the riots that hit and
everything then everybody knows the
story
yeah so well here we are impressive
thank you very much
thanks for the mug i'm glad you're here
you hit me up
hold on before we get there please
promote whatever you want uh so
you know where things uh you can find me
at
um cut take two i'm on uh adam rigg
comedy
on instagram and twitter
atomraycomedy.com
uh for uh for tour dates which you know
there's a few there but they're all
pr you know stay tuned for changes at
um adamraycomedy.com a cartoon i'm a
voice on right now at hulu called
crossing swords
it's like a filthy medieval time show
from the robot chicken guys so it's all
the uh
stop motion uh with little peg people
and tony hails on it and seth green and
really really killer cast real fun and
uh and then a couple albums out read the
room and songs for the people on spotify
and itunes about last night the podcast
which you've uh
crushed many times and it's a great time
we'll crush uh we're not it's now sans
dwarf
so just just a jew but uh i probably
should change it to just a jew
i'm now realizing the missed
opportunities out there also at some
point
lean into your audience and when i see
like seinfeld or
or um what's his name avi lieberman
right like does he shows in israel and
it's always just
jew city and uh
yeah i'm like god do i just but i don't
i've got maybe two jokes about
being that are even you know soaked in
anything religious
and uh uh to really
but i've done a lot of like i was about
to say synagogues but
i've done a lot of like jewish uh uh
centered shows or at um you know uh
community centers or
fraternities that were all jewish and
you'll make a couple jokes that are
catered towards it
um but i always see i guess what i'm
saying is like look at fluffy his
audience or a [ __ ]
uh you know kathy griffin's got uh um
you know uh the gays uh
really uh you know she's got
she's got that's a makes up a big part
of her audience it does
[Music]
i just want to say this is officially
the worst plugging
i've ever heard someone do for their
self i've heard 20 other comedians
you haven't said [ __ ] about it we're
only 2 30 yeah
you're like i got a website but if i can
recommend the air up there with kevin
bacon it's a great movie
i saw it just recently it holds up
uh billy ocean's greatest hits my
favorite album from the 80s
saw billy ocean live put a pin in that
story that's a good one
with my pops he uh got me into billy
ocean but okay so the the cartoons the
podcast
the twitter adam ray comedy
kathy griffin i'm coming after the gays
don't stop jesus christ
hey man it's friday oh you know it is it
is
20 years ago i'd be watching uh patrick
duffy and bob saget try to corral a
family of five you know
i do know tgif did you prefer that i
you know what no i watched i was a big
thursday night guy always which was like
fall guy night rider then it was like
cheers right uh night court [ __ ] like
that i remember the thursdays
i don't really remember i wasn't a big
uh what was that full house oh right
right i'm a little older than you bro
are you yeah i'm 47. i got you bro wow i
always feel like you're younger than me
so take care of yourself you know i i
still run i'll still run a 464.
you know what i'm saying
dude i uh worked out with um some nfl
quarterbacks for this uh
podcast uh with mark sanchez called um
uh fourth and forever that short time
sports was doing and
we got to go down and work out with you
know like josh allen and sam darnold and
mark
jumped in the mix and it was a true test
of like
oh man i feel like i'm in decent shape
but then
you know you get out on the field i'm
stretching as much as i think is
necessary
and then just trying to run routes and
that was fine because i
can do that and know how to turn enough
and get to a spot quick enough to where
they
but uh at one point they go josh they go
[ __ ] as hard as you possibly can and
i saw a little bit of like yeah and i go
what are you guys talking about
you gotta talk you guys talking about
how you can't believe about that the
athleticism that i'm
displaying right now and they're like
two which was my lane
so i just take off and i and i run and
then i just turn and stop
and dude you can tell when someone's
just like
trying to end your life right in the
storm
there's there's a look in the eyes of
like i'm gonna [ __ ] toss the ball to
this kid who
wants to live out some dreams versus
like there's no way this isn't gonna
cause some internal bleeding and so i
get to the sideline and caught it and i
was miked up and everything too and it
knocked me to the ground
and i go was that game speed and he's
like i try to throw it as hard as i
could i go
as hard as you could he goes pretty hard
i go that's what i'm saying as far as
you could
because i need to know for retelling the
story if i caught it and i was just like
did i take your best shot yeah yeah
we're gonna take your left no yeah
but he's like no i put some uh some
serious gas on it and it [ __ ]
and he also like i'm wearing a can a
gopro and then a mic
dude he hit me literally right here i
mean
crazy i've heard stories old receivers
of elway they said through their
shoulder pads and everything he would
they would get the cross of the ball
right there like and so for you to have
that yeah
i i had something interesting happen to
me recently i was wanting to actually
talk about so it's pretty cool was it
the sports relationship okay so
i've been touting all juco since
back in the day i was all juko i played
soccer i made you know the
all juko whatever and wait now what is
juco juco's junior college
great for people that you know as i say
the the
13th and 14th grade i thought it was
like all jewish community center sports
because you don't know about me i'm on
all your flyers
because we had wesco for all those
sports so juco
yeah so um and i you know i always [ __ ]
around and but i'm
the truth is i always say be the best
wherever you are yeah and that's i
didn't have them financial means to go
to a four-year institution my grades
weren't
they were okay i got a 3.0 but it wasn't
that's fine enough to go
to you know pay i had no parents i had
no support i had no nothing community
college was my only option it's great
that it was even an option right yep
and i i lived with my grandmother at the
time and she lived like a mile from it
so i went and i would go
i would get up i would go to school and
then we would do soccer right after
and then i would go to um
deliver the new york times all paper on
yeah
but a driving one all the way down to
annapolis i worked till four in the
morning and i was doing this every night
still playing soccer
still making the all-star all juko [ __ ]
how many years did you do the paper out
just one okay i couldn't keep up i
filled in for a buddy four times
and was like contemplating ending my
life yeah
i mean no appreciation i was like doing
an open mic you're throwing the paper
you're like
here you go and they're oh no one's up
it's 5 a.m yeah yeah
all right so so you're still doing that
and crushing all the sports
so i recently have uh orlando brown jr
on
the podcast from the ravens amazing sky
hits me up
and um he says
you know i graduated a couple years
after him and i happened to be
a coach at your your alma mater
junior college holy [ __ ] like no way and
he's like we got a spot for you
so he sends me a shirt and um
i hit him up and i just thank him man
and he he sent the nicest letter to me
well i wasn't expecting he's like look
you know
you're you know you always
are proud of junior i go look i know i
joke about it but i am proud of
like my beginnings i'm proud of where i
come from should be proud of how it
started i'm proud of
everything i've done to get to sit right
in this chair across from you
all contributes to it so
um he sends me the nicest letter and and
he says
we've got a spot for you if you can pass
the conditioning test so i was like huh
so i call them and i'm like first of all
i want to thank you for
what a great letter and um i go what's
your [ __ ] conditioning test so you
start to tell me one of them and i'm
like break it down for him all about
that
that he sent me another one i was like
look i was thinking about bringing a
crew with me to shoot a little fun video
but i saw this conditioning
that i was like
yeah well it's gassers but all in a
certain amount of time you're doing 100
and
200 yards or whatever and then there was
another one that i i mean it was just
like i think he said you had to run two
miles and 12
and even my best i was a i could do i
could creep out
one at six yeah one i ain't i ain't
hitting that again
around four laps not happening not at
47. not what these knees
i could go still kick a ball around i
can't you know
but anyway that's amazing it was awesome
and he he told me he's like you know
there's
a couple kids on the team there's one in
particular that's got a
trouble with the law and typical
baltimore upbringing
um and he's like and i told him about
you and i told him you came here and i
told him you played here
and he's like i want you to know it made
a difference he really
couldn't believe you started here well
there you are and it made a difference i
was like whoa so they sent me a
a jersey and a post i'm gonna or a a
nice letter i'm gonna make a post about
it but that's amazing
um yeah [ __ ] hell yeah come all the
way back around
it feels good to you know reflect
every now and then and go oh cool
because you know everyone suffers from
this from just
straight up looking this way not even
checking the rear-view mirror for
for uh for a heartbeat and to like when
people like that
recognize it and bring it up to you
which is also 25.
yeah so here's the other thing like and
christian kershaw
is his name and i i hope i didn't [ __ ]
that up um
not related to clayton i did it
he's i think he said he's 25. wow you
know what i mean like right this guy is
not even
he wasn't even born when i started or
right when i finished
you know what i mean and and my one of
my coaches
his dad is friends with and knows so
it's awesome to have these guys even
know who the [ __ ] you are and then throw
some love your way so appreciate y'all
catonsville community college i think
you called
i don't know what you're calling now
ccbc or some [ __ ] but you always y'all
was ccc all juco when i went there
um all right so you called you texted me
yeah
and you said i really have something i'd
like to talk about yeah
and can we talk about it of course what
if i just was like
you know what i thought about it a
little bit more on the drive over and uh
nah let's keep talking soccer yeah so
my coach that really influenced my life
with greg tacon no uh uh
yeah so you know i think you've done a
great job of really
making the focus uh you know um with the
low lights
and so which is great because you know
we talked about on the pod and
right after the last time i was here
sorry if you haven't
watched adam's first episode that's the
whole
i heard it in your throat clear dude
it's my one-man
show if i ever want to do one i really
want to work on it at a chunk of time
because we basically just opened by
reflecting on my mom and dad talking for
the first time in
maybe 10 years on facetime when my dad's
in the hospital
potentially on his death bed him
apologizing to her just
very having all these mortal thoughts
and and morbid thoughts
and thinking about mortal kombat and uh
don't know i don't know
he's looking for a third and uh whatever
he's playing mortal kombat
asking her for the cheat codes she's
like cheating you know everything about
that you know
anyway so too soon all right no that
added up actually pretty well but so
uh so that was real emotional and then
we went through my mom's dating history
which was
[ __ ] i hadn't done and to do it with
one of the best to
listen and and tag and observe dude it
was
i appreciate you letting me be a part of
it it was so much fun it made me
i was surprised at how much i could
remember and and you just bring that out
of people but
so so in in sticking with the theme of
just
uh you know mom and dad and and folks
and
and you made uh that experience
comfortable to talk about all that stuff
and i remember getting
you know uh emotional about some of it
but it you you uh
you're just good at making people want
to talk about stuff that they
normally wouldn't so this falls right
into that so i was
um in oregon once this pandemic hit
my stepmom uh who passed
uh was dealing with stage four cancer
probably
she was about this when she passed it
had been about two years since the
diagnosis
and you know she was okay and it's
starting to not feel well in a lot of uh
you know um a lot of treatments and a
lot of just pains and
clots here and there and urinary just a
lot of other complications
my dad's you know still working it at 75
you know an internist at a
va clinic in oregon and trying to stay
focused but
just his you know wife is just you know
uh
fading away and a lot of mixed feelings
because
you know and as i uh said in a facebook
post trying to like sum up my feelings
it's like
it's the the woman that is dying is his
wife
and who i've gotten to know for i guess
since now 91 is when i think he left my
mom
for her okay so can i stop you there for
a sec so
yeah 91 when we talk about how good the
bulls were no you just completely
cheered i graduated high school let me
tell you about my graduation yeah yeah
i'm in the esses
okay now they start with days
uh so this is the woman your dad
left your mom for correct ended your and
started a new family right
and my mom my dad even told me thought
they were gonna get back together
and my dad uh and then once
we i think even when my dad had my
stepmom had a kid and then
my pops and stepmom had two kids
together who were my brothers half
brothers i was calling brothers
but you're close to them oh very very
close was there ever any resentment i
don't remember with your stepmom at
first because she's the other woman or
no uh for me yeah more so my sister
i i just went into it very i was just a
very glass half full
also i could see and i i think i don't
think i was
a bad kid innately but i became a better
kid
be uh as a default from seeing this the
the trouble my sister was getting into
and the pain it was causing my my mom as
a single mom
so i try to be on my [ __ ] even more and
help her
clean the house when my mom was on
before she got home from work and just
do things to
try to do my part to make things a
little easier and so i kind of adapted
that when
my dad started his new family to be like
oh just act
like literally walk in and be pumped to
see this woman and it'd be like
because i'm thinking of my dad i'm like
i don't want to make it weird for him at
[ __ ] eight i'm not thinking that's
not a maturity
it was a lot of fun for any age well a
lot a lot of pills but they uh
no no no and uh a lot of flintstones
vitamins baby all that calcium gets you
thinking straight
um so he was uh he was it was weird
though because yeah you're over
at his new place with this woman and her
kid
and then they had my um brother logan
and
my mom didn't know about it and then
they were we were told to like not
let her know about it and then she found
out and that's when my that i think is
when she filed for divorce because then
it was like
you know there's no you don't hear about
yourself you don't hear about your
your your husband's having a kid with
another person being like
well i'm gonna get bug bit
i'm gonna wait if there's one more kid
then i'm out you know that's it and it's
official two more
is it twins you're all thin nice yeah
so that was checkmate and then uh and so
then
she uh so that was just me sister and
uh and mom and then now you're just
dealing with this back and forth of
going over
to my dad's new place with you know was
your sister having the same problems
she was two years older than me and way
more uh locked into
[ __ ] this she's also a girl so totally
she knows better
and my pops left on her birthday which
my dad just told me too he was like
i think it was on her birthday yeah damn
and yeah
and uh and and so that was
she's a little more sensitive to all
that obviously
and uh and i was like i even asked him i
was like do you remember like was it
during cake or like he's like i don't
[ __ ] do you think i want to go back
then you're like
listen i'll say when it was it was right
after 2u
[Laughter]
i even held the ooh as i walked out the
back i [ __ ] walked
so they thought i was just trying to
harmonize in the car
i heard some people singing in the back
i want to make sure they could uh bounce
for her birthday man hardcore
you know and they've since made up and
and you know dealt
with that but so again i wonder what she
wished for next year
oh man yeah yeah
yeah man dad i wish you were never here
well guess what shit's about to happen
yeah yeah
yeah man so now you just she's very
uh just not cool with
the change and so i think it affected
and never was or did she come around
no no only i had that flag and held it
up dude
on both of those respect for people like
me too man like what who am i to say
like
uh and even you know she ended up going
to a um
girls school uh when she uh i was just
eighth grade
through high school with my mom and i
because my sister uh stole my mom's van
and her boyfriend uh and god
yeah my mom's ran and her and her
boyfriend took all my clothes all my
money all my mom's [ __ ]
and drove to arizona to like work at a
[ __ ] gym or something i don't
remember what the plan was but they're
going to open a cold stone i don't know
what they play
i don't know dude that was the most
surprising part i get back my piggy
banks open all my [ __ ]
albertson's checks were gone and i'm
like
you know did i i'm like [ __ ] did i sign
him over already and then all my clothes
are going i'm like [ __ ]
i had some key items in there like some
michael jordan t-shirt some sean cam
hoodies
some [ __ ] the original patrick ewing
shoes that nobody had
and uh and so uh they got stopped on the
way to arizona my mom's like i can't i
have no control
gotta send her off to this girls school
my grandparents like yeah she's gonna
end up dead you have no control i
thought she was helping
and you know a lot of resentment from my
sis towards my mom this whole time from
that which again i get but then at some
point you go
mom's been crushing it for you ever
since creating so many opportunities
helping with you as you had twins by
yourself and then just struggled
struggled struggled
has been nothing but there for you so at
some point the resentment's got to
[ __ ] come to a halt
and you got to be grateful and you got
to stop being ungrateful
and uh and you know my brother-in-law uh
when they got married has helped with
that because he comes from very little
and
seeing my mom and and me and the help
you get and go hey
[ __ ] it could be worse i know it can
be i've dealt with it i would have
wished i had family that was a
supportive is so
dealing with that resentment and
resentment toward my towards my dad and
she's kind of leveled out on it finally
uh and with my stepmom probably in this
past year once she got sick
really kind of f just you know things
get way more real when someone's on
their [ __ ] death bed
i mean it doesn't get any more real than
that so did they become friendly
or did she reach out just nicer yeah
reached out and just was nicer and more
concerned and really
more concerned and and uh worried about
my dad's
uh emotional state and so that actually
kind of helped repair
their relationship and she because again
just
couldn't and he finally kind of
apologized to her which i think allowed
her to just
drop it finally and live your life and
holding on to hate
is such a an overlooked piece of um
emotional wear and tear i think it
causes i think it can cause cancer i
think that
that just manifests that yeah blackness
in you just oh yeah you know can
grow into something that kills you yeah
yeah you go
all of it dude my uh you know jessica
cass uh
uh stole aaron domingo for me in the
eighth grade and you know am i over it
we'll see at the end of this podcast but
you know if i pick up the phone and call
but i think
if she picks up you know but uh there's
there's been things that i've held on to
that i'm like man this is just
not doing me any good but you are so
just you've you've
you've kind of uh given up on trying to
reason and you just
you kind of like feeling that you know
enraged which i think everyone at some
point
you know whether it's being the victim
or just being so jacked up about like
this is i'm
i'm so i'm getting so [ __ ] on this uh
you know you want to kind of like lean
into that and and go yeah
i'm allowed to feel this pissed but at
the end of the day
you know cancer yeah
so good night everybody uh
[Laughter]
your stepmom so so so she's yeah so
she's kind of cancer
it was uh stage four liver and that's a
[ __ ] yeah you know that's
game set match so then it's just keep
you happy keep you comfy
um and she was doing all right and what
came to my shows up in portland and when
i was up there with dane
uh brought them up and and we went out
to lake chelan which is eastern
washington to renew their vows my dad
was like it's really important i think
i don't know how much time we got left
it could be a year could be five years
she's feeling good
we'll do it now we're feeling good so i
got a big aaron b and got some shows up
there to kind of
balance it out and brought all uh their
kids and
and my girl came with me and my nieces
and my sister drove out and
it was great it was good time and she
was able to partake in some stuff and
then was kind of sick so kind of chilled
a little bit
but got all these pictures and video
from that and it was real special and
important to both them and especially my
dad and that's what the focus has been
which is
uh make it easier for him somehow and
be a part and really kind of quickly
didn't even think about all right i'm
gonna go up there for
a month and change at least and then
however long after
uh to kind of be there with them to
distract them and keep them
somewhat normal and and happy and and
keep make sure that he knows that he
still has a life right to live
during and then after because 70
just turned 76 and so uh
that's a real thing too which i didn't
totally understand is the heartbreak
that can
uh go down after your spouse or a close
person dies where you're
you know by yourself and i know it was a
thing with dogs because i saw it happen
with my sheepdog
but i didn't know that i don't know that
people possessed the uh
you know that that same trait sheep
though
yeah man when george lost gracie that
was [ __ ] that was a wrap in 1998 for
his uh his stay on planet
98. the bulls were great that year too
that went smash mouth dropped all-star
yeah
so so she got real bad real quick and
then it was like all right how do we i'm
gonna get up there and my brother logan
came down so wait they gave her from a
year to five
uh no initially uh no actually i think
it was
maybe even god was this two years maybe
two
max or maybe six months she outlived it
i know that
and actually was fine she was somebody
68 or so no 66
68 i think 68 maybe 66
um but in good health otherwise
smoked a lot though man i mean it was my
first taste of cigarettes was when i
would be
in her van and she'd be driving my
sister and i and her son somewhere and
you ain't stealing this
i dare you to do it i'll tell you
the voice is spot on also
the space work is phenomenal but dude it
was my first taste of
of maybe secondhand smoke yeah as a kid
first taste of secondhand
dude i've never been
that was my first day wait was that my
third
[Laughter]
just trapped and the windows are like
all closed she's hot boxing the car
with [ __ ] joe camel and i'm just like
in the back and i remember the first
time she yelled at me i cracked the
window
and opened and it was one of those
windows that just did like it just
opened like
just a little bit yeah that little so
you're like no this is
such a smallmouth base i was doing that
i cracked open a little thing and i was
like
i'm smoking the oxygen that's free
outside and she sees me in the room from
here and she goes oh you can't stand the
smoke
and i was just like get out the kitchen
that that he makes sense
what is it bloody devots driving us
[Laughter]
so i'm just trying to get some clean h2o
or uh [ __ ] whatever oxygen is wait
what is the what is the oxygen just o2
i'm trying to get some o2
and i'm and and she's she was annoyed
she was just like oh
sorry i some you know sorry i smoked it
just really and that was my first taste
of not only secondhand smoke but also
oh this is this is a weird dynamic
what is what is my role in i'm on i'm in
her car
we're staying at her house it's also my
dad's but like
i quickly kind of also saw that it was
weird for my dad too i didn't really
because now he's we never talked about
it so it's just like hey yeah
good to see you like he'd pick us up and
bring back and bring back to
this is my new house and you're just
kind of like and again i just be like
cool
that couch rules and again i kind of was
also like oh i got two houses now i got
two
it's kind of fun but just again trying
to make the best of it
and but you did you hated it or you or
you didn't yeah
no i mean at the end of the day i saw
how
upset my mom was and how i but
any time i would start to get a clean
grasp
and really feel like what was happening
i just would try to
distract myself move on go play a sport
made friends in the neighborhood where
they lived and go kick it with them or
what was your stepmom's name
uh renee renee yeah and then you would
see what it's doing to your mom and
oh yeah and and like you know what mom
renee says have a cigarette yeah
on her actually ah chill out yeah yeah
yeah take it easy yeah yeah i mean how
bad would that be coming you know mom i
know you're stressed what works for
renee
you know my other mom it's my other mom
yeah i mean that's think about that
that's a dagger that's a true start to
the heart
that's just [ __ ] a mom that'll kill
any mom
right there like oh yeah knowing that
there's so i mean
i remember they would just fight my dad
would drop us off and they would just
there'd be some fight about something
money something
and also just contentious my mom i mean
i didn't know so my dad told me like
thought they were gonna get back
together and then he
because i think she just was like wait
try to make it work wait your mom my mom
did said she was going to try to my dad
says he's like i think your mom thought
we were going to get back together
divorcing happened right away when he
left and yeah yeah the kidnapping what'd
you say
what did you say i was like wait is
there a plot twist in my own life it
happened oh it happened
it was a rap one again
happened what kid by the way kidnapping
happened
is a [ __ ] it's my new next album
the kidnapping happens oh my god that is
some kid and play
vanilla ice they have the same manager
maybe
let's take a quick break to tell you
about our sponsor talk space
change is always a constant but these
days it feels like there's something new
to grapple with
every day we may be adjusting to this
new normal but it's still stressful and
it's important to talk about it
and seek support talkspace online
therapy is here to give you that support
because we all need it right now
match with a licensed therapist from the
comfort of your device and reach out 24
7 whenever something's on your mind
you'll hear back daily
five days a week all right you know i'm
big on
therapy you know i believe you should be
out there talking to people getting help
and
you can do it here and it's affordable
it's a fraction
of the cost of in-person therapy but
with talkspace
you can send unlimited messages to your
therapist and they'll engage with you at
least five days a week that means you
never have to wait to share what's on
your mind talkspace
is secure and private using the latest
encryption technology
to store client information the bottom
line is that we all need someone to talk
to and talkspace wants to give the
license support we deserve
at a price we can afford as a listener
of this podcast you can get 100
off your first month on talkspace to
match with your perfect therapist go to
talkspace.com
or download the app and make sure you
use the code honeydew
to get a hundred dollars off your first
month and show your support for the show
that's honeydew at talkspace.com
now let's get back to the do so so now
she's given this short
time frame and again your emotions just
go through the roof want dad to be okay
and also again not having someone
this close to me be on uh death's door
again like with brody and and other
friends that uh
passed in this last year or so which is
the most probably i've had in a year uh
but somebody's hospice or at home yes so
she got real sick then she went to the
hospital and i'm
now i've been in la then went to arizona
with my girl's family and we're like
let's just
you know it's their things hadn't really
taken off uh like they are now in a z
as far as people just being like you
know you ain't stopping me from going to
quiznos
and so uh so now that's you know a place
where we can chill
so then my dad's like i don't know man
i'm thinking that there are people out
there
that have said that sentence all i
remember is some sound bite of someone
with a gun on the courthouse in michigan
being like all i want is a haircut
and a ding-dong and not in that order
we'll be right back and the news guy is
like you can't throw it a commercial
it's my
my program and so we go up to oregon
because my dad's actually in the
hospital but now
the pandemic is hit and now it's like
what the [ __ ] we can't even
yeah uh know for certain if we're gonna
be able to go to the hospital and you
couldn't
at one point and then my dad's like wow
it's just gonna be like this then and
now
now i'm like all right i gotta get up
there and be with him and my brother and
i
uh uh were there together for a while
and then traded off
uh weeks and uh trying to keep motivated
and
distracting the set and then finally
they were able to get her and it was
uh the consensus get on hospice so now
that's crazy hospice which by the way
texted a buddy of mine that on like day
three i'm like hey can i hit you back
my stepmom's on hospice ten minutes
later he hits me up he goes dude i feel
like such an [ __ ]
i thought you said your stepmom was on
hospice i thought that was some new
dating app i'm like well she is leaving
my dad
um swear to god hospice i'm back and so
now i'm laughing and i
i didn't show my dad that but uh but
i'll hear about it on this but um
but uh so now she's home and now we can
at least control the environment keep
her comfy
and that's the whole goal is make sure
that she yeah i mean what else is and i
kept telling my dad this because as bad
as it would get
with you know you have good days where
she's eating she's responsive we could
get her up in the wheelchair bring her
out to the
the living room and she could hang and
see us and
play with her dogs and and and be
somewhat uh it just didn't feel as bad
as it
was and my dad was doing okay and still
having her
in the other room was great you know and
he could work and check go check on her
and
so when he would get down though i'd
have to remind him
like i felt like i've always done with
the glass half full approach i was like
dad
she could be in the hospital and you
couldn't be able to see her at all she's
home she's comfy
and you can talk and he's accepted what
it is and but he couldn't go in there
for too long he'd sometimes just lay
with her and just sob
and then he's like i can't be in there
couldn't even be in there for one night
he's like i think i'm going to
sleep on the couch it makes me too sad
to be in there but then i then go in
there because you want to be with her
and you don't know and
then some days was real bad and a lot of
pain and and just reel up and down and
then she'd be good then she had a week
where she was
it's probably three weeks in the hospice
just eating more and and
and feeling good and responsive and
talking to people and
sitting up and coming out and and then
it just kind of took a
just took a turn and she just wasn't
wanting to eat and
you know my my brother's now about to go
into medical school and
and my dad you know being a doctor then
it really and then but even as
a doctor my dad not wanting to
give in he's still feeding her when
she's like i don't want he's like still
off yeah
and the hospice nurse is like at some
point there they just don't they know
that if they don't eat or drink anything
that's it but they she knows that and
just seeing
the whole progression uh
you know or the decline of her health
and and just going downwards is just a
a really crazy i mean just to like
watch it for about you know i was there
for about a little over a month
and so being with her and two months
before that where she was you know
fine and good and coming on my shows and
so to see her just in her bed and
and losing all the hair and then just to
get real thin and then
i go in there and talk to her for a
while and just be real responsive one
day and ask questions and i'm just
trying to make jokes and this and that
and then anything you need and all that
and
then you also sometimes she just wants
to sleep or be alone but then i feel bad
because we're in the other room watching
you know uh you know shanghai nights or
whatever's on tnt and um
i don't know and uh that's a good move
that's a great pool
that is a great idea and so uh we're in
the other room
trying to live a life but there's one in
there that's ending so yeah
you're feeling guilty by so you're kind
of going to check but then you got to
keep dad
busy and happy and uh we're bitching
about you
papa john's got the butter sauce yeah
yeah you know you got to watch it
dude a thousand percent make sure
that you pick your complaints while
there's hospice two doors down
make sure you don't go god there is
nothing on netflix who the [ __ ] put the
batteries in the controller wrong
god damn it dad are you sure the wi-fi
password is
your name
yeah so so that's hard to
to forget dumb [ __ ] like that sometimes
you really have to remember perspective
becomes a big
every component of uh what you who
what you uh really latch onto during a
hospice
uh wow i can't believe i was about to
say showdown
uh a hospice situation sometimes your
brain
knows the word but picks a different one
and you're like
yeah that doesn't not make sense but it
in the context of what you're saying
uh in the hospice uh situation
you know you uh you
don't have a lot of control because
she's just like you're kind of going off
of how she's
wanting to feel and how she does feel
she's a lot of pain then there's always
a point where the morphine's gonna have
to come out
and to kind of subdue her and and take
everything away and
and then uh and would a person come by
or did they stay
no no hospice uh so my brother would
stay there and then i got a hotel and
then we'd kind of swap out
and um like how did they do that during
the virus the
person came in a mask yeah and stuff
yeah and uh
and then my brother would you know take
care of bathing her and cleaning and
all that stuff yeah he's a [ __ ] saint
and just crushed it
and um and uh
and it was weird because my other
brother not so much uh
because they you know it was just a
weird that's right they had two kids
yeah and they you know it was again my
pops
and uh had to um you know bounce around
working different hospitals uh for
uh 10 12 years and stepmom and
brothers were back in eastern washington
and and there was some disconnect there
for sure and then when my brother logan
went to college
uh my younger brother mark uh got a
little
uh neglected and so that relationship
gets weakened a little and and i think
you know
so so there was just emotions at every
stage and at every level
uh but at the core of it like everyone
just wants you feel for the person who's
losing their
wife at the end i say it all the time
like you do
you know we selfishly will lose this one
person but that one person is losing
everyone
every single person they're losing you
know here are my kids here's my husband
here's
everybody i'm losing my dog you're
losing it all we
feel for or if we feel awful we're like
oh i lost my my dad or my mom or my
whatever but your dad or mom
they lost everybody yeah you know yeah
and it was
again what was crazy is trying to sum up
like
we talked about the beginning this is a
woman who my dad
left my mom for so that's but you
you push that aside it's not like
there's i'm not hovering over her bed at
any point being like
you made me feel so bad about hiding
chips under your couch i was a fat kid
and you know what karma's a bit like
there was no part of me that was
you know you know still holding on to
yeah what you know but
there's a little bit of you trying to
process like your emotions towards
because i was very
sad but i i got choked up a few times
uh you know pretty substantially but
again you're like
all of my concern is for my dad and
emotions i think are living there
and again i don't want her to be going
through this you're seeing it on her
eyes
it's if you're a human with any beating
heart and and piece of a soul
you you get very uh it's just very a
very raw thing to watch
and to take in and and you cannot feel
like
you so helpless because you're like [ __ ]
i wish i could
make you not feel like this and i wish
you could come out and laugh with us and
hang
um but again like
you can't i can't stop any thoughts of
like
it's you know well i know why i'm not
like on the ground sobbing because you
know and
so i can't um you know uh
ignore that that like oh this
like and not and look there's two sides
to it my dad chose like they
decided together to start this life and
my dad also left it's not like she
pulled my dad away yeah but
but still right like uh
trying to decide how you feel about it
and then i think
what i learned is you know you just
gotta kind of feel how you feel like
don't
try to get in the way of all right like
just be a [ __ ] rock it's like no if
you need to [ __ ]
if it's if it hit me for some reason
like when my sister obviously stole my
and your pancakes sucked too
never liked your breakfast
always cook me that olympia i wanted
[ __ ]
mcgriddles you saw me gasping for air
back there
um so you know that's why and i i gave
you that post that you can either you
know
uh share or uh or not but that was my
attempt
i put on facebook and trying to again it
was such a
and i've been trying to do this in more
facets of uh
my comedy and just my uh voice in
general
be a little bit more introspective with
things like this and a little more
connected to
experiences like this and and and
sharing
your feelings and point of view uh as
you're going through it so i i posted
this thing on facebook because i was
like well this is where i'll
be able to just not censor myself and
kind of
and i really didn't i went back because
i had a couple little um
typo things but i just that's what was
crazy too i just was i got so
moved by uh you know her passing and i
was in there with my dad for her final
breaths we'd
gone back and forth he was like she's
having a bad night i was at the hotel i
had to get up early to do
some voice over stuff and i was like you
know what i'll just uh
stay over the night and if i i'll push
it back a little then i'll go there
later but
i don't want you to be by yourself with
her tonight if something happens over
the night so i stayed and she woke up
and i walked out and
dad's sitting on the uh on the couch and
and uh and he goes well she's rene still
with us and i was like
awesome you know [ __ ] he's just kind
of said it a little
you know somewhat somber but just kind
of like you know today's not you know
it's monday it's not gonna be that bad
of a you know hey
we'll see here we go start of the week
and then we went in there and then he
uh said oh man she's just she's doing
those
those deep heavy breaths uh and so going
in there and
and checking and just kind of talking to
her not responsible obviously
and you know a little bit kind of you
know and then uh my dad went back in and
then i went back in and then
and then we just uh there and then i
walked out
and then he walked out right after and
was just crying and was like oh and then
he
so he sits down and he immediately
starts to try to call people i'm like
dad dad just
chill like live in this moment for a
second and you don't have to do anything
but i also i understand you're just like
i gotta start telling people yes
i also need to stop i know he's just
losing it
and then we sit down on the couch i'm
like oh let's come sit down
you know and i'm trying to keep my
distance from him too he's 76 i'm not
we're not touching each other
this whole time was masking it for a
good chunk of it and then just stopped
because i hadn't gone anywhere but i'm
trying to keep my distance still and
sitting on the couch and just kind of
you know holding this
his hand and and uh
and i'm like let's turn on the tv and we
turn the tv and and trump was on or
whatever and
you know like you know you know you
maybe put sunlight in
your pee hole you know and my dad was
like i can't watch this i'm lighting
your pee
oh whatever it was you suggest no no
what if that's the thing
what if that's everybody holding
holes over the sunlight up in your feet
listen as crazy as everything's been why
not
that might be the [ __ ] thing you're
not a doctor how do you know that's not
how
god don't burn yourself but if anybody
tries it out there please let us know if
it works [ __ ]
people were stunning their [ __ ] why
not bro dude why not
look this america is based on trying to
see what goes where
and uh and and i think that there's
there's something about sitting down and
tv was like a great distraction
i changed the channel it's jerry
springer and
my dad's like this is fine and he's just
crying and just and i'm just sitting
there and silent
and kind of turn up a little bit and
then we look down and one of his dogs
is just pumping away at this stuffed
animal like it's a me too moment for
sure like this dog is just
going their little poodle on this little
stuffed gnome and
even then it was like i was telling my
buddy i go
like this toy it was i've never i've
seen dogs hump toys before but
the the little like gnome thing even
like kind of like got
was getting humped so that his body was
moving towards me like almost like
you're not gonna say anything
come on yeah yeah and so uh
and so i'm looking down and it it's it
reminded me of this time
where three months prior when i was
visiting them that same poodle doing on
the gnome
and my stepmom was like this real real
kooky character
and real real fun real quick too and and
that was the one thing that once
i got older and started to let
more of my guard down that was up even
though it was always cordial and nice
but started to really kind of just get
to know her per just be
accepted more and saw how funny and
quick and sweet she was and
and and just you know the the good times
between my dad and
and she and and and she did this thing
that i think a lot of non
comics will do and especially relatives
well they'll say [ __ ] out of character
because they're like oh you're a comic
you can spin any sort of [ __ ] i
might throw your way and make it into
some sort of you know hilarious moment
that we can all enjoy and i don't i i
feel safe that i can just
say things but also she was getting sick
and this was i don't think things were
lining up right so she'd just say like
my [ __ ] hurts sometimes and you're just
like
[ __ ] cool i just asked what time it
was but you know you know
and you know it's hot listen i'll be out
back getting some sunshine in my dick
hole
okay but she would just say like
funny it wasn't like tourette's it was
just like she just would
and and it was fun it was fun funny and
so
so seeing this uh i see the dog going to
town it reminds me of a time
where that's happening three months
prior my stepmom we all looked down
where i was kind of like oh man you know
and then my stepmom looks up at me and
goes well at least someone's going to
come tonight
swear to god swear to god
at least somebody's going to come
tonight which is basically just being
like you know
that that like hey like shots fired like
you know and so
she says at least somebody's gonna come
tonight which i say oh what
and then uh we're looking down at the at
the poodle still just going to town
and so i think of that as i'm watching
this and here my dad and i are again
watching uh watching uh uh jerry
springer and it's a real intense
uh by the way my dad laughed at that too
because he just he thought she was
the sense of humor the sensibilities
were on point which was great which i
always
which i i know he was felt guilty when
we'd be out there having a good time
laughing because they did that a lot so
i think he was just it was tough for him
he'd laugh really hard this was the
saddest thing that i
saw from my dad was laughing really hard
and having an
honest and he's got a great like you a
great laugh infectious makes you feel
good
whole face lights up just you want to
make the person laugh right now it's
just like a goal of mine when i call him
to get him to get that
just really deep guttural belly laugh
and he had would have those and
immediately followed by just
like like like really hard and then just
like just uh why can't how come she
doesn't get to
do this with right and i like it's or i
feel guilty having
this much fun or or just all that is
packaged into that
immediately after and that's so sad and
crazy to see such a contrast of
uh it's an emotional rollercoaster of
just and so he was just
and that's what you're constantly
battling while she's over there my
grandmother is italian
both of them were but my my dad's mom
was an artist
my friends still do it we still make fun
of her teaser a little bit cause
you know it was always my dad died i i
never looked at it as a parent
until i had a daughter and then i wanted
to call my grandmother and hug her she'd
long die but i was like oh my god i
i'd be devastated if my daughter died at
42 years old you know and i had to live
through that
so um my but my grandmother would
cry first and then come out and she'd do
the opposite she was like oh my son's
never gonna come over again
have y'all had some cheese i mean
she would [ __ ] drop it like that like
grandma is that cry even real like
don't you tell me i'm not crying for
real oh my god all the time
would you like a sandwich all the
they're saying that we might have to
stay indoors for another two months did
you know when i put the sporks
that's exactly what was second but it
was always to take care of you you know
what i mean like
have you do you need something oh
because as soon as she feels too much
she's like
i'm being greedy with these moments what
do you need right now
that's a classic mom grandma things
legit
um yeah man so we're sitting on the
couch
watching jerry springer turn up the
volume
this is why i this this matters it's
just the the what was so crazy is
finding what do you do in that moment
after she passes there's no rule book
for that
it's just you're truly what do you go on
a walk do you
go sit in there in the room with her he
couldn't go in there
even when they were taking her body out
he was like he had to go in another room
and and lock the door he just he's like
i can't watch them take her out he
dreaded that that was a very sad thing
that he said he said a lot of sad things
i had to cap him at one point i go cause
they have two little poodles one of them
is blind and deaf mindy she'd be just
bouncing into [ __ ] walls like a
pinball machine she couldn't tell if
that was a toe or a wheat then
she's just like
she [ __ ] was not
it was it was cruel to keep her around
and so
at one point we and she had this giant
growth [ __ ] some dr pimple popper
could not even fix and she's just
clawing and chewing at it and walking
around with this [ __ ] just
[ __ ] a couple of nut sacks spooning
each other and she's just like is
everything cool
hey do you guys see where that toe was
like that was a cracker you are [ __ ]
up and so
my dad's like we just got to put her
down so he did two days before my
stepmom passed
so stepmom passes the other dog's
walking around
you know very melancholy knowing that
something's wrong
is in the room sitting on the bed laying
where my stepmom would lay
uh because she would stay by her side
the dog that was uh still with us
my dad at one point when uh sophie the
dog that's still with us comes up since
it's my dad and he's petting her and he
goes
uh so he goes yeah he's like you boy
you've had a rough week you've lost two
moms in the last two days i go dad
i gotta stop yet this is [ __ ] like
this is
i'm hey yeah feel all the feelings but
that's six
depressing statements in 24 hours and
i'm here
i'm gonna be out back with mindy getting
some son of a dick no mindy way to put
minnie down
[Laughter]
we're watching jerry springer and we
turn it up and it's a classic
you know dante you have something you
want to say to chantelle he's like yeah
he's like i've been [ __ ] your friends
and everyone's like oh jerry and then uh
and then she's like that's a lot of
information chanterelle anything you
want to say to dante she's like yeah
uh well what did she say she oh she goes
up uh i got a surprise too it was just
one of those classic
i'm not what you think i am she's like
i'm a man
everyone goes crazy they zoom in on this
guy uh dante i think it was his face
and jerry's like dante that is a lot of
information she's not uh
is a guy and he's like i'm good with
that
i start laughing my dad starts laughing
as he's crying i'm like
all right maybe tear it up a little bit
i think this is just what the doctor
ordered
a little bit of a little bit of j spring
to kind of take us
back to reality and and kind of escape
the darkness for a minute
and uh and he's kind of laughing and
then
i think it's one of those things where
just the comic brain comes in where
you know uh you know we've been seeing
the
poodle hump the gnome when renee said at
least someone's gonna come tonight so
we're sitting there
the guy's like i'm good with that to
this girl that is a dude
and look at my dad i go at least
somebody's gonna come tonight and he
chuckles a little bit
and [ __ ] cries a little bit more and
then i was like
you know and i and he's such a hassle
too i was like i was kind of like
waiting for a little bit more like
yeah that's pretty good that's that
should [ __ ] i think we're out of the
the darkness oh that was [ __ ] that's
the joke that's gonna turn things around
and uh
ships right yeah yeah and it was uh but
but we watched a couple more episodes of
jerry springer
and then just sat in silence for a
little bit and then uh
and then uh and then you know they they
come and and take her body out
and um and then it was just weird and
that's just weird that
i mean he's there for that yeah i stayed
for another maybe 10 days and my brother
came down
i mean literally did you stay in the
house oh yeah i watched them take it
yeah
i mean i walked into after my dad
couldn't go back in when i walked in and
just kind of
said some things to her and they'd done
a whole church prayer with her over
a zoom thing at one point and um
actually my brother logan tells me a
story
that my stepmom's uh i think cousin uh
at one point on the
on the the sermon zoom thing with a
bunch of people and she's still
cognizant at this point and still i mean
sick but still
able to respond more than she could in
in weeks before she passed
and my cousin's just distraught and
emotional her cousin
and my brother says she just goes god
just lord
please renee's just sick and we're gonna
miss her so much but don't let her
suffer anymore just
just take her god just take her now just
take her god
and my brother goes to my brother goes
my mom my stepmom literally just goes
the [ __ ] is she talking about right now
i'm still very much i can hear you
[ __ ]
just take her god just take her like i'm
still fi i've got a vitamin water right
there
i am [ __ ] not going anywhere
is that a [ __ ] i know figured out
yeah
dude i'm so glad i remember that detail
because my brother told me that i was
like
you can't write that [ __ ] and the fact
that and
he said and he said to because he
laughed and he he
he was mentioning how these are one of
the moments that he was
wanting to remember and because it was
so
at that stage you have your memories pre
everything that you're going through
pre-hospice
but obviously during that time there's
going to be other things you think about
so you want to try to find some of those
positive gems to hold on to and that was
one that was so funny they told me tell
that [ __ ] not to pray out loud anymore
[Music]
can you pray in your head please all of
a sudden you say it you gotta say it out
loud cause you're on a zoo
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you share with the
neighbors yes not with the person
no it's losing that or [ __ ] typing in
the chat to the pastor yeah yeah
sorry miss spell can you tell god to
take her now i feel like this is
something i should not say out loud in
front of everybody
especially her send god
so uh so that moment after was just
crazy man and then and then we're i'm
there for
10 days after just to get my dad back
into
onto a a into a routine and get some
rhythm back uh
to uh to his life because you're just
like
and you're making us how long were they
together what was it 20 years 28 years
old
91 to whatever yeah yeah and so
and he so he's done the thing where go
through photos and pics and a lot of
people reached out and
and his birthday was about a week after
and i made him some really fun birthday
video with um
some friends and and of his and friends
of mine and
and some uh cool people that i uh have
got to be
uh come buzz with that he's you know
really keen on angela johnson
was like one of their favorite comics
and she sent a really heartfelt message
which was incredible it was all for
wishing him a happy birthday and i told
people what was happening just to
be like you know not saying they needed
to mention it and angela did because
we watched her special that day too and
they had gone to see her together and
she had a really like i know she's a
sweet uh
girl but this was like a very touching
thing and my dad was just sobbing about
renee and just all these nice things
just about what he she'd heard about her
dude he said he's watching the birthday
video like 30 times
because he [ __ ] makes them feel good
and so uh
did dante call in
you should fight with that guy you
should find that real guy
no [ __ ] happy birthday for your no [ __ ]
because
first got to make him smile post pass
i'm saying man that's powerful that is
powerful
uh that's so funny but so you know
now he's flipping through uh albums
you're going through this up and down
situation of like i want to
move on and be happy but then i don't
want to move on too quick and so you
just let him go at his own speed
and be there distract i felt like i was
my brother as well like crushing it as
far as like
i mean as soon as i would feel my dad
start to sulk and go down and say
another like you know
a good thing we didn't have birds
because i probably would have [ __ ]
killed that
it's like dude again yeah let's stay on
the positive train yeah
so i was anytime you would sulk i would
just jump in with conversation about
sports has bonded us big time comp we're
just you know
and uh or something funny that happened
to me or something that was never sonics
they're gone
[Laughter]
oh my god that was a big thing that held
us together too
that's [ __ ] dude i know
and then sport yeah but then like sports
getting yanked away it's all gone
i mean it's also a bad time to lose
anyone because everything's getting
peeled everything's getting taken away
and then so now you're like [ __ ] i can't
leave you know and um
and so we got him back into a good
situation talked to him today i just had
a cataract surgery so now he's seen a
lot better which
helps um but you know there's
uh i took him and my nieces and uh
and girl uh and and brothers down to the
oregon coast
with him i thought we're gonna do an
ashes uh uh shake
drop what do you do with it what do you
pour it sprinkle sprinkle
sure well you're not taking it out yeah
it's not like a pepper shaker
dump you dump them you dump them spread
dump is not spread's probably the
sweetest better one of uh
but you are you're dumping you're
dumping them yeah because you're
yeah i think it's a spread what movie
was it was it magoo
spread spread them out was it maguber
were they
no big lebowski do you want where it
blows in his face yes okay
great yeah is that what you're thinking
yes yeah also due date had a really
funny one where he put it in the coffee
can and zach galifianakis i think drank
it
um
uh so yeah so so man
be you know so what did you end up did
you do that did you go
spread her ass i haven't done that yet
that's uh that's
uh tbd but um you know i think he wants
to do it
uh at a place they in lake chelan
eastern washington
got some gigs up there in the fall we'll
see if that holds up but uh
but yeah man i i i hit you up because i
was like this is a very heavy
and um i'm sorry man i know that's heavy
where was your shower two months ago
dude
what if i really meant that i would love
it i would love it
and that's how it is and i would hold
this episode even longer
we recorded in uh july but it's just
going to drop for the fall moon
okay the auto moon episode
without a rail
do you is there are you that facebook
post i did do you even want to pull that
up or is that not
necessary what do you think won't you
post it i did
i mean post it when i post the episode
add it to these posts repost it
yeah why not yeah it's worthy of a
repost
is it isn't it about how you really feel
about someone passing
yeah oh wait wait post it with yeah with
all the stuff i'll post for your
oh yeah included yeah i guess let people
read it
isn't there though a little bit of
people being like dude what are you
trying to milk some more likes right now
like what's going on like what are you
reposting uh no my fans are great they
don't they're but i do hope they say
that now since you brought it up and if
they do it's only because you brought it
up you put that idea in their head
yeah i don't know so what yeah
trying to put the
uh what you're feeling through that
whole time into words is what i
was trying to do with this post uh i
mean i because again it's like
mom that is you know a woman i
care about i don't want to to see suffer
go through this
dad love your brother's mom yes
uh trying to gauge everyone's emotions
and take everything into consideration
and just be a rock for everybody
not uh suppress my own emotions but also
not
i was also like it's not i'm not here i
don't know dude i still
and then and then talking to even my mom
about uh uh
stuff uh she'd check in and ask how he
was doing and how she doing and
very concerned i wanted to oh yeah
they've been around each other i asked
my mom one time have they
no no i mean have they have your mom and
dad i know they're reconnected but have
they talked since
if anyone that should have said take her
now god it should have been the cousin
she should be my mom if you're gonna
really break it down
if she was on the zoom prayer your mom's
like
i co-signed that like who the hell's
emily she's ready yeah
uh no my mom was so sweet and but have
your mom and dad talked since your
stepmom passed away
no but i think uh texted or
or they've communicated no actually my
mom was my dad couldn't be on the prayer
but i think
my mom and stepdad were actually on the
zoom prayer thing as my brother reached
out
um and so and he told me last time i
talked to him
for me to thank her because he thought
that was he didn't know that and he
thought that was incredibly sweet and it
was
um so uh so yeah dude
death being that close to it is and and
being in the room with someone as they
i mean leave is i don't
it's you can't uh yeah
i mean i at least she went
silently totally and also it's
volumes to be that's right to be a good
enough person that the way you got to go
out was with loved ones around you in
your own home i mean what else could you
ask for when you're gone
a thousand percent i had to again
continue to remind my dad of like the
alternative here
is so depressing what a bummer if you're
having to look at her on an ipad while
she's taking her last breaths
and she's scared and you missed dante
you know say
[ __ ] you know you missed a nap yeah
yeah well bro i love you i love you too
thank you for coming here and opening up
and sharing all that yeah um
and laughing about it i appreciate you
letting me take shots at it
and laughing along it's you kind of
and that's the thing too that that going
through
um something like this and and having a
courtside seat
to a hospice that doesn't sound good
being
this close to [ __ ] dude i gotta pick my
words better
i i see what i want to say and i just
don't say it
i got a sky box right outside the
funeral home okay
like what
are these scalper hospice tickets four
seats to the hospice show
no so you know seeing going through that
it it uh it gives you so much
perspective
and uh because again how
you know comedians friends from high
school these things shake you up in
their own way
and brody was devastating on on a myriad
of levels
and and uh you know and
personal connections and and then just
also
you know the the tragicness of a death
like brody
and then with something like this the
tragicness of man
68 like not yes it's got plenty of juice
left in the tank
and healthy otherwise and just not you
just want at this age to have
more and more uh awareness of like
wanting your parents to
like right off into the sunset truly is
as
lame as that uh or overused as that same
may be like
you you definitely want that that's why
trying to ease my dad
into back into a routine that he goes
[ __ ] being around is still pretty
cool you know and getting bummed is
gonna happen
but i've got a lot of things to be
grateful for and and i'm still ticking
and
and helping out these veterans that i'm
uh you know uh
being a doctor for and still got family
that's doing everything and i'd tell my
dad to i was like look we're [ __ ]
not doing all this because you know we
we're getting paid to like uh you know
we
we we want you to you know stick around
and and
and not fall into a depression to where
you're like you know
i gotta [ __ ] you know get out there
and get some sunshine up and get cold
you know ain't nothing gonna make you
feel better than a good one
from sophie dry hump a gnome get some
sun in your pee hole
and [ __ ] put on some jerry springer
that's it yeah dude uh one more time
please promote whatever you'd like yeah
baby uh adam raycomedy on instagram and
twitter adamaraycomedy.com he's got tour
dates and
and just all my video content and uh uh
about last night podcast is the podcast
on spotify itunes youtube
um and crossing swords on hulu right now
uh
and the bellman is a movie i'm in with
thomas lennon that's out on amazon
so go check that out all right brother i
love you guys i love you too
man uh ryan sickler dot com
ryan sickler on all social media talk to
y'all next week
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]